les amis aujourd'hui ta grand chose
pourquoi parce qu'on va jouer à
cela un petit parti bah oui boys aux
autos qui n'avait pas joué un petit jeu
japonais fendard j'ai dit fendard
l'opposition peine tea party c'est un
jeu de combat où tu joues une culotte
une culotte oui eh ben je vais pas vous
vitaux il est extrêmement bien notée sur
steam
une évaluation positive avec près de 24
d'évaluation ce qu il est un très bon
jeu épisode zéro la guerrière de l'amour
fait mon arrivée elles ont des stats et
tous ok on croyait l'aïoli cas elle se
trouve c'est super technique à la
culotte parle je la trouvais olala ça
fait plaisir 3 peu de japonais je dois
me dépêcher où je ne serai jamais alors
en cours waouh tune qui parle j'ai dû me
cogner la tête
on part sur un scénario hollywoodien
c'est soit séquelles du pilote la gare
de l'amour je suis transformée en
culotte tu es capable tout en sonnant la
cloche c'est la preuve que tu es la
guerre de l'amour oui je suis vraiment
un si petit en train de voler on joue
vraiment une culotte qui vole la 1
mondiaux clic gauche équipe sur fois
face aux attaques continues tient
culotte blanche
je peux envoyer un rayon au fantastique
votre passion votre passion je suis
énervé voilà je slip della vela qui me
les coûts y aller c'est fait on est une
très très belle culotte je suis en train
d'émettre je suis en train dé mais je
suivrai oui je pense pas que ça
arriverait l'ol dimanche est vraiment
puissant dit d'une guerrière de l'amour
oublie la guerrière de l'amour beau
temps sur mon imac une autre dakar ne
t'inquiète pas c'est déjà fait moi on a
la charmante fille que je suis de retour
qu'est ce que tu m'as fait ne pense pas
que tu vas t'en tirer comme ça tu parles
à une culotte mais fait part en courant
juste à l'épisode de ces partis
j'affectionne ce jeu et je déconne même
pas la vérité c'est que les culottes
mal-aimé menée par ponzi veulent
attaquer tous les humains à leur faire
un lavage de cerveau
c'est quoi ce souci que ça sera fait les
usa sont forcés de les mecs que les
culottes
[Musique]
non donc tu vas arrêter pas même si
correct le seul amour est vrai que
l'autre vient du fond du coeur des
humains à regarder dehors ils nous ont
trouvés pour la culotte bakar
d'embrouiller les mecs dehors pour
montrer sa puissance est gelé des
molières gelé des molières capitale sont
nombreuses la ola là c'est le rush des
culottes
elles sont dues aux tourelles plus
culotte salle olof palme et venez là ça
sent la culotte mec je me cache un train
très hard quoi bon grog
elle est morte elle martèle lâche et
passe en mode passion mec j'ai un
complexe de huawei vient là on va faire
des choses sales
oh [ __ ] elle est vénère elle a peu
mode pas sûr mais que ça décolle pas du
lot à pois mais t'as pas honte d'être
aussi laide arrêté
et de me tirer dessus voilà ça dégage et
toi en te fignon réunion et plus
l'enfant ses vinyles à aller victoire sa
fête du slip jeu bon énorme
aya qutrième donc sa couche culotte rayé
toi aussi tu as rejoint ponzi l'est et
je être forcé les met toutes les
culottes peuvent par leur type qui
n'aurait jamais pensé que je vais de mon
ennemi kg trier sonné je vais devoir
utiliser cette technique
viens te battre il est où il ait opté il
appelle ses comptes en fortes white et
le baht a quelques tapas elle son ménage
un peu dégage voilà pour le rêve de
pommes du samaa aux [ __ ] qu loterie
et va casser les couilles mec je le sens
il aggrave de la vie en plus il vient et
carragher un pote à lui quoi devait n'y
a pas de respect à un truculent il
existe par a
ils sont plusieurs pokémon passion il
est où l'autre vient là bien à bien il
fait le mec est allé trop chaude
acculant trier moyen âge des démoli j'ai
des volumes mais on a fait trop de vies
ça va être serré mais qu attend sagement
son mode tu vas tu es nerveux au pap
non j'ai pas de culotte j'ai un caleçon
il s'est enfui on n'aurait pas dû le
finir et l'interrogé non t'inquiète pas
fière de la mort j'ai peut-être un plan
en ce sens de la merde ça sent la merde
en plus on parle de culotte donc sa
culotte ours et une culotte de niveau
légendaire très réputé pour ses skills
surprenant il ya un amour le prochain
big nous allons rencontrer ne m'appelle
pas lié à l'amour [ __ ] à propos de cet
allié il a l'intelligence de ponzi et sa
puissance au combat est considérable
mais c'est une culotte et la vente avec
une forte personnalité culotte cool cuma
et voilà la culotte source aluminium
cette culotte on aime bien on l'achète à
la japan expo vu madame mutual mauvais
goût je vais te donner quelques conseils
ouf des jeunes comme toutes les chaînes
n'avaient pas cette date et ne peut pas
être le gars de l'amour quoi tu vas
devoir s'excuser auprès de toutes les
scènes du monde
j'ai atteint pendant six mois même que
la tour se fait sortir les invités on va
se battre contre la clôture ou à la
culotte source obtient sa bosse à temps
ce sera sans moi de passion
oh que ce que je dis il faut que tu la
classique visite et je m'en réjouis a
fait trop mal auquel a cédé aux
classiques l'annoncé devrait faire
tranquillement team 400 tu t'es
transforme en culotte j'imagine que tu
es vraiment guerrière de l'amour mais
quelle importance puisque une lycéenne
qui a passé la nuit d'expiration je ne
la suis vrai que si elle aime le pilote
source de tout son coeur et plus que les
autres on est vraiment en train de
participer à une querelle de culotte
d'accord donc là on va affronter la
culotte insolente pour montrer que on a
un amour à conditionner pour les
culottes
chaque lot à sa propre cour octave
évanoui à l'étranger avec l'envoi des
obus j'ai déjà là bien là bien là bien
là même si j'ai à hpv de baisers ya ptet
les vénère au hall mnr on va mourir moi
c'est la mort ce nom bon il nous reste
une vie ça c'est la bonne nouvelle on va
défoncer à ça fait mal au corps à corps
monga les culottes sa botte des culs lot
voilà c'est qu'il a ramené que l'autre
menant ensuite la taille de l'école
hausse avait l'air bien mais moi j'aurai
le mans d'arca je vais tester d'autres
culotte pourquoi j'ai pas de culotte
[ __ ] pourquoi ces dlc non banneret pas
dlc bah franchement j'en aurais bien
acheté aux peugeot occupe du coup le
mode arcade c'est quoi c'est une seule
culotte as un tournoi de culotte année
on en est vraiment là et qu'ils se
gênent je gagne je gagne un truc à un
faux pas est ce qu'on m'envoie une
culotte par colissimo une fois c'est la
question doit pas se mentir ce que je
commence à gérer un peu le le slip
qu'est-ce que je débloque une culotte
s'il vous plaît car ça joli tournoi ok
je mets ta plus grande chute et culottes
avec je veux faire du xxx l armée sous
trop est ce que je leur mets là d'un
gage commence à l'industrie du bois au
[ __ ] c'est quoi ça la culotte marina
viol où on va là-bas on va l'avoir
c'est bon là you want et la culotte mois
on l'appelle le maire même si qui l'a
été par des [ __ ] de haut mais il est
venu au le med gym avec you know il va
me tuer non mais le maître mot gay il a
une passion pour rien quoi al matin ils
arrivent à munich et [ __ ] les
trottoirs non franchement sa vie je
résiste comme je peux mais c'est chaud
voilà [ __ ] je l'aimé à un tiers de sa
vie quoi il est trop dur
ok ce parti on l'a à distance on va lui
faire une charge dans cinq des leurs à
comprendre ce qui est arrivé
arrête de tchité et la mort il a pu
depuis la petite vie je fis nos rayons
non c'est comme ça contre attaque et
l'autre qui se prennent pour des bouées
dans un bon jour le plus pur c'est quoi
le boss diesel pour voir le boss assez
youri calmos direct et la cua hadassah
la même comment en fait à l'escwa savent
aussi les regarder se dire je me fais
violer par une culotte ça non mais
laissez le même que moi sauf qu'elle
joue dix fois mieux au [ __ ] t'as gagné
l'aquila couronne les culottes
alors là tu as gagné mais je te laval
avant même que tu les bâtards bons des
âmes et choix qu'on a fait parler de
culottes et qu'on a c'est jouer à ce jeu
voix de fille nue si vous aimez la
culotte n'hésitez pas à aimer la vie
c'est sûr ça faisait mal jusqu'à c'est
l'un des rares jeux japonais sur steam
qui était vraiment bien noté quoi et en
plus heureusement il est pas mal le
système de combat et tout ça marche bien
il ya ces difficultés l'histoire il vend
c'est le seul truc à part on est
d'accord
un temps fort c'est un homme avec des
culottes mont cassel c'est dur n'hésitez
pas à me dire dans les commentaires des
gens des culottes vous avez c'est faux
je m'en bats les couilles au [ __ ]
allez on arrête tout ça dès maintenant
et je vous dis à très vite dans une
prochaine vidéo portez vous bien la
culotte c'est hyper drôle on termine là
dessus et c'est bien dommage à revoir
[Musique]